جلبت الحرب الكثير من الأرض
محاكمات حزن ودموع لنسيانها
مستحيل ولا مغفرة ولا مبرر
أولئك الذين يخططون مرة أخرى للعدوانية
الخطط
ما يقرب من قرن يفصل بيننا الأحداث عندما
في وسط أوروبا أصبح وقحًا ودفع المفترس
يجبر الوحش النازي الوحشي جميعًا
شعارات عنصرية و
التفوق الوطني
معاداة السامية ورهاب روسيا بكل سهولة
يشطب الاتفاقية المطلوبة
توقف عن الانزلاق
تاريخ الحرب العالمية يتطلب القيام به
استنتاجات لتعلم الدروس ولكن للأسف
الكثير من أيديولوجية النازيين اليوم نحن
نرى تجمعا لمعاقبوهم غير المنتهين
يحاول المتابعون إعادة كتابة التاريخ
لتبرير الخونة والمجرمين
على أيديهم دماء مئات الآلاف من المدنيين
من الناس. من العامة
يعرف شعبنا جيدًا ما هو كل شيء
هذا يؤدي في كل عائلة هو مقدس محفوظ
ذكرى من انتصر ونحن
سنكون دائما فخورين وقطط روسيا
التمسك الدولي باستمرار
بينما سندافع بقوة عن هذا الحق
مواطننا
من خلال ضمان سلامة
اشخاص
[موسيقى]